foreign
supporter of the multi-world
interpretation of the schroding your
equation that governs the wave function
of the Quantum of quantum mechanical
systems uh are these splitting off
worlds infinite and number we'll start
simple
oh it's not known and it doesn't make
much difference to the theory whether
they are or not but I think the
Infinities you were talking about the
cosmological ones they're different from
the quantum mechanical uh universities
the universe is uh that are that are
invoked in cosmology our universes with
different laws of physics and so on and
there there is a genuine problem if if
there's an infinite number of them
there's a genuine problem that that
means that no predictions can be made
about them because uh if they're all
equally likely that that doesn't mean
anything because then then their Pro
each of their probabilities is zero
strictly zero
so uh that that's completely different
from the uh uh quantum mechanical
universes proposed by Hugh Everett and
by Schrodinger by the way uh which I
think there is uh incontrovertible
evidence for and which precisely do not
have this measure problem so if the
cosmological infinity is To Be Tamed
some way of solving the measure problem
for them has to be appended to the
existing theories because if there's a
finite number of them like 10 to the 500
then there's still an issue there's
still an issue of whether
the number should be regarded as a
probability I think not
okay there are many questions that one
have I do understand the multi-world
interpretation is theoretically the only
interpretation that doesn't interpret
the the Schrodinger equation it just
takes it at face value and doesn't have
to go through any type of uh decoherence
or anything else we'll we'll get to that
but I still want to pressure you on this
is you know is the number infinite or is
it just you know so many gazillions that
it it that you don't know can you get
give an answer to that
well I think it's not known that then
then it could be it could be a number it
could be it literally it could easily be
infinite uh the number of distinct of of
distinguishable universes is more likely
to be discrete but it could still be a
discrete Infinity like the the Infinity
of the integers uh rather than
continuous Infinity but we we don't know
in either in either would that be an
Infinity in both uh temporal directions
backward and forward I I'm asking maybe
naive questions but these come to mind
when I hear about them yeah no it's not
naive now you're you're raising you're
raising the question to involve quantum
gravity as well because different times
are special cases of different universes
but what that means in a specific Theory
we just don't know that would require a
theory which unified general relativity
and quantum mechanics and we don't have
a satisfactory one of those
so you know it's funny I don't know I
would tell you if I did no I know I know
you do you're not bashful with your
ideas that we know for sure uh George um
when I first started the multi-world
many years ago I mean you know the first
reaction is you know is that a joke you
can't believe that but as I began to
understand it the the measurement
problem uh is real in quantum mechanics
and the multi-world interpretation
claims to be and may seem to be the only
literal approach to the probabilities in
the Schrodinger equation but you know is
this cure worse than the disease
well you see I start off with a very
different position from David unders he
said there's indisputable evidence for
the um Everett Multiverse I I don't even
begin to believe that so we start off in
such a different place
um and and I I really have to raise the
problem here the the the shredding
equations a linear equation okay and the
idea appears to be and I've been having
a debate about this that there is one
function away function of universe which
obeys this equation and that determines
everything is that right
yeah so if that is true
then how do mice and atoms and sheep and
cows and birds exist I simply cannot
believe that one function linearly
evolving results on all of that outcome
so so we start off in completely
different
um position
um and uh to just to explain that a
little bit I believe there are local
wave functions everywhere in the
universe but no Global wave function and
that makes it puts a whole thing in a
completely different perspective so I
just don't have this problem with all
these branching functions and all the
rest of it because on my view there are
local wave functions wave function
collapse takes place locally depending
on local conditions and I never even get
near the problems that David is
approaching because I don't have this
infinitely branch and wave function so
Sarah from from your perspective
um looking at both the measurement
problem and quantum mechanics and the
measure problem in a potentially
infinite Universe in in cosmology
how do you uh how do you dig below that
to get to some fundamental questions
um so I don't take either of the
theories seriously when you get to that
stage so I think like there's a tendency
to take theories and they have sort of
an explanatory domain and then we always
want to push their explanations beyond
what they're actually designed to
explain and what they actually tell us
and I think that can be useful but I
think in some ways that extra operation
is quite poor so for example the idea
and the Multiverse that there's you know
uh an Infinity of copies of me doing
this somewhere is to me a sort of a
gross overstep of what the Theory
actually says because quantum mechanics
was designed for a certain type of
phenomena at a certain scale of reality
and one of the reasons a measurement
problem is difficult because it has to
deal with observers and how is it that
physical systems that are information
processing systems or acquire
information from another physical system
you know what is the physics of those
systems and I see that as being a
completely different domain of physics
than what quantum mechanics describes um
and that has to do with the physics of
evolving systems systems that generate
information and use that information to
actually make new possibilities occur
and there's traces of what that looks
like in quantum mechanics but I don't
think quantum mechanics describes it so
I think this idea that Multiverse is
actually taking uncertainty that we have
about microscale phenomena assuming the
entire universe is that when we actually
live in a completely different space
that's constructed along specific
trajectories where information has been
building up over four billion years on
this planet to make specific features
that are us that are very local
structures and probably don't exist
anywhere else I think to tease apart the
different ways that we're approaching
this question we're using the word
infinity in many different respects the
Infinities
quantum mechanics is is a radically
different kind than the Infinities in
cosmology I think we we recognize that I
think there are then questions of uh in
epistemology both from an experimental
and an observational point of view is
George stresses and from perhaps a a
cognitive capacity uh obviously escaping
from uh hyenas and jaguars on the
African plain did not
um by force give us the capacity to
understand quantum mechanics so we our
brains evolved for a certain things I
think that's that's Sarah's point so I
think I think rather than blur all these
different ways of thinking together we
need to teach them apart and address
them separately so Sarah one more
question for you is that um in in the
measure problem in cosmology because of
all these Infinities uh and you know and
and because of the nature of infinity if
something is even remotely possible if
it's not they put a reverse it's not
impossible in Infinity to occur then
that almost The Impossible thing but not
impossible will also occur an infinite
number of times maybe with with the same
level of infinity so it becomes very
complicated if there were an infinite
Universe which you don't believe but let
me put the the counter factual to you
how would would there be implications
for identifying intelligent aliens which
is your life calling
yeah
um
so the interesting thing to me is that
question doesn't actually make sense in
an infinite Universe
um and what I mean by that is I think
um the fact that we live in a finite
universe and there's some locality to
where we are is in part how I can
explain our existence because the
information is built up over time
whereas I think if you think
um you know there's no new physics
needed in life and biological things can
just fluctuate into existence anywhere
it suggests to me that the information
necessary to generate a living thing a
complex thing exists at every point in
space-time everywhere and therefore
there's nothing special about it and
there's no Evolution or knowledge to be
gained by the actual physics in the
system and I don't prescribe by a
philosophy where everywhere there exists
the design of complex things
um David
um I I want to ask you this question
because as I've been dealing with the
multi-world interpretation and thinking
it absurd at first I've experienced the
fact that over these couple three
decades the multi-world interpretation
has become more and more accepted by
more and more Quantum physicists so why
were you right uh in the in the fabric
of of reality you talked about this as
one of your four big Ideas uh why were
you right and I was wrong why are there
more people now committed to the
multi-world interpretation what's been
happening
uh well one thing is that people are
trying to build quantum computers and if
you if you want to ask how a Quantum
algorithm works then there's really no
choice but to work out what it does in
each of the separate branches of the
schroding equation or what and and one
of the problems with
um well a major problem with trying to
confine theories or ideas to the realm
for which they were invented
um like like the the Tigers and whatever
it was you know ancestral no Lions it
would be wouldn't it uh in our ancestral
environment then then the the trouble is
you would be forced to say that uh the
theory of quantum computers
for which the theory the quantum theory
was not invented should be abandoned
shouldn't be explored
um and uh and they won't work
uh and even to this day the universal
quantum computer hasn't been built
so no that no such computer has ever
been experienced by anyone and the
theory was not designed just to describe
it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas